so some of you may have noticed that
there's a problem with YouTube today and
I'm not just talking about Oh YouTube
should listen to its creators more oh
they should do XYZ differently I am
talking about a fundamental problem with
the website itself and this isn't just
about me I'm not making this video
because I think that I'm being unfairly
treated in any way shape or form if
anything I'm in a really good position
but this is affecting a lot of people
and I think the reason for it needs to
be brought into light now if you were
paying attention to YouTube you probably
noticed that last week last Tuesday on
October 16th the website went down
worldwide for two hours it went down
which has never really happened in
YouTube before and a lot of people
wanted to know why but I have a sneaking
suspicion that I know exactly why and it
all comes down to one culprit Google+
and I'm not just using Google+ as a
scapegoat and it's easy to do that
because it's a terrible thing that was
forced on all of YouTube for no
particular reason other than Google
wanted to to give you a little history
on Google+ and why it's so deeply
ingrained in YouTube you have to go back
to 2014 when Google decided that it was
going to be mandatory for creators on
YouTube to get a Google+ account you
have to tie your YouTube channel in to
Google+ no matter what it didn't matter
if the service was good or that they
cared about natural growth they wanted
to force it down people's throats so
that they could have a Facebook
competitor now this isn't about the
morals of Google+ being integrated into
YouTube that's not what this video is
about and frankly I'm not the best to
even argue about that I'm telling you
this to emphasize how deep this really
went to see how much of YouTube had
Google+ embedded inside of it it came
down to every single programmer being
incentivized to integrate Google+ as
much as they could
they had bonuses implemented into
Google+ so that programs would be
rewarded the more they were able to
force it into YouTube's code and with
that in mind that leads into today
because before the crash on YouTube on
October 8th I believed it was announced
that Google+ was shutting down
completely because of some embarrassing
privacy leaks Google didn't want to be
exposed to regulations so they shut it
down completely
try to avoid any fanfare about it and in
doing so they have fundamentally
crippled youtube so Google+ isn't dead
yet but it started the process of
shutting down as they're shutting down
Google+ it is breaking more and more
things inside of YouTube and these
things are still broken and they're
getting worse now now it's almost a meme
at this point that people are like my
videos aren't going out to sub boxes but
now it's actually a problem across the
board a lot of youtubers are seeing a 30
to 40 percent dip in the number of
initial viewers and prolonged viewers
suggested videos aren't working properly
people aren't getting there and
notifications properly there's a lot of
different recipes that are causing
problems it's not enough that it's
completely broken but it's enough to
create a noticeable difference and an
impact on the bottom line of a lot of
youtubers just to show you how deep this
actually goes if I go into my channel
here this is this is basically my
channel the back end of my creator
studio where I manage all my videos
there are certain pages in here that
just don't actually work if I click on
these pages in here some of them take up
to a minute to load some don't load it
at all they just break and I've told
them about this and they still haven't
gotten back to me and I think the reason
is is because they don't know how to fix
it and I think that's the main problem
with YouTube right now the problem is so
big because Google+ was so deeply
integrated into YouTube they have no
idea how to separate it out at this
point so here's my guess in what
happened they pushed a code change on
Tuesday that caused all of YouTube to
crash they reverted the change and now
they're trying to analyze exactly what
happened and because it's so big they're
gonna be very slow about it
and the worst thing about it is that
this wouldn't be nearly as big a problem
if YouTube actually communicated that
there was a problem you can't just
pretend that there's nothing wrong on
the platform for people like me those
who are high up on the platform
I don't really have a problem with it
because I can weather these issues month
to month but there's a lot of creators
out there that can't that really rely on
this on a day to day basis
and as much as this is a fun job to have
as much as it's cool to entertain people
there are people that now like rely on
this rely on the consistency of it the
sad truth is that we are called partners
with YouTube but we're not partners
we're less than employees YouTube
doesn't actually care about its creators
and I'm not saying that in a very like
all the world's ending YouTube doesn't
care about us they legitimately don't
because they can't or at least they
don't have the system in place to do so
they can want it they can hope for it
but until they put the system in place
that actually gives benefit towards its
creators nothing's gonna change people
are still gonna suffer there's still
gonna be this negative attitude towards
YouTube because they rely on code and
algorithm as opposed to real people
interacting with the real people who are
making content on this platform and
until they treat the humans that are
making the content with humans that are
supporting the content it'll never work
I might be wrong about the specific
reason but that doesn't change the fact
that there is a problem with YouTube and
it doesn't change the fact that YouTube
won't tell us that there's a problem if
YouTube is gonna be a place where
creators can thrive and people can make
whatever content they want then you got
to start treating us like people all of
us if we really matter show us that we
matter and even for someone like me who
gets preferential treatment on these
things I'm still kept in the dark about
it I have to tell them about the
problems with their own platform that
they refuse to respond to me about and
if they treat me this way
what do they do to people that have less
subscribers than me it's not okay it's
really honestly truly not okay they
shoved Google+ down the throats of
everybody on this platform and now
people are suffering from it because
they don't see this platform as a place
for creativity to thrive they see it as
a tool to push their agenda and that's
fine they own it it's their right but we
help build it so anyway let me know down
the comments if you've seen other issues
with the platform if you've seen other
issues on YouTube try to keep it not so
much about the morals of it and try to
keep it down to the technical issues
that are happening
right now we've got technical problems
that need technical answers
communication is an issue and hopefully
that it'll get fixed soon but for right
now let's try to fix the problem so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
one bye bye